what uh right-wingers do is did you know
that back in seventh grade he was once
tardy and I we heard that in eighth
grade he was smoking marijuana he was
evil and had it coming did you know
George Floyd might have stolen 20 whole
dollars oh my God these black people
they're so evil did you did you know
that Trayvon Martin uh it
was you you so I can understand if
conservatives and right wiers have done
that and so you're just frustrated and
don't want to hear it but I'm not doing
that it's but it's
you you you're taking the most extreme
cases with the most clear racism with
the most clear murders and you're trying
to Nuance it tracks a huge right-wing
audience cuz they want somebody to
excuse the death of Ahmed Arbury and
George Floyd and when you seem to excuse
it with your Nuance then they go yes
finally somebody's sticking up for white
people killing black people come on
don't tell me there aren't people in
your audience that think that what bro
what are you talking about man